tja wir schalten gleich weiter zur
gustav gräßel ist militärexperte herr
dressel ich grüße sie herzlich erklären
sie uns doch bitte noch einmal was ist
da passiert militärisch in den letzten
tagen vor dem wochenende wie kam es zu
der rückeroberung durch die ukrainische
armee von ja ungefähr ein dutzend
ortschaften
wir vorliegen einem dutzend größerer war
schafften es die kleinen dörfer mit
zählt dann natürlich ungleich mehr wir
haben eine letzte woche begonnene
offensive gesehen die auf dem fluss
tiegel gezielt hat die auf eine
einkesselung von lithium gezielt hat der
ukraine und die diese operation hat
eigentlich zu einem zusammenbruch der
gesamten russischen front im nordwesten
gästen geführt die die die russische
verteidigung im kiefer und last ist im
grunde zusammengebrochen und die
russischen gruppen haben versucht
entweder die region komplett zu
verlassen haben sich ergeben weil gerät
zurück gelassen sind zu fuß geflohen das
hat natürlich diesen diesem großen sieg
der ukraine aber ausgelöst dass die
ukraine das auch geschafft im zuge
dieser offensive jetzt weitere
geländegewinne zu machen über wichtige
fluss hindernisse hinweg das heißt
selbst er jetzt meine pause sehen weil
vor allen dingen natürlich dass
treibstoff
nachgeliefert werden muss heißt das noch
nicht dass das ende der fahnenstange ist
das kann kann auch so weitergehen das
heißt sie setzen auf weitere erfolge der
ukrainischen armee wir haben vor ein
paar wochen immer gehört dass die
ukrainische armee kaum noch munition hat
beziehungsweise dass die militärische
übermacht der russischen armee so groß
ist ist das jetzt nachschub zum beispiel
in munition oder auch anderen geräten
kein problem mehr erwarten sie weitere
erfolge der ukrainischen armee
also die die problemlage war die dass
die ukraine zwar die soldaten hat seine
eine gelegenheit am fußball garten
gegenüber der russischen seite aber
nicht an schweren gerät nicht am panzer
nicht der theorie nicht dahinter
schützen kanzler
dass das ganze hat dazu geführt dass die
ukraine ihre eigenen offensiven sehr
genau planen muss weil sie nicht die
kräfte hatten auf breiter front einfach
die russen zu drücken das haben sie sehr
clever gemacht indem sie monatelang
schon darüber geredet haben in class
sondern eine offensive durchzuführen die
russen tische form sehr stark verstärkt
haben jetzt ist es so dass auch nordufer
des merckle wohl mittlerweile alle
brücken und auch die meisten fähren die
über diesen fluss führen zerstört wurden
ein großteil der operativen reserven
russlands liegt die die russische
führung jetzt eigentlich bräuchte um die
situation in kharkiv zu gereinigt und
das gibt der ukraine mehr
handlungsfreiheit und
das schafft jetzt diese möglichkeiten zu
rücken diese löcher in der russischen
front durchstoßen können es braucht aber
weiterhin natürlich nachschub vor allen
dingen aus dem westen weil natürlich die
material lage im gegensatz zu
personallage auf der ukrainischen seite
prekäres verfahren seiten haben jetzt
ein noch deutlicheres personalprobleme
sie vor dieser offensive ja und wir
haben auch in bildern auch gesehen dass
mutmaßlich westliche waffen oder geräte
an den aktionen beteiligt waren die
jetzt zu landgewinnung oder
rückeroberung
geführt haben dennoch
tut sich die bundesregierung schwer mit
der lieferung von kampfpanzern
konkrete leopard 2 wo zieht man
eigentlich aus ihrer sicht die grenze
also was sind eigentlich schwere waffen
und kann man die tatsächlich oder kann
man das tatsächlich an einem gerätetyp
fest machen oder ist das eher eine
künstliche diskussion also die
argumentation der bundesregierung ist
völlig irrational
die panzerhaubitze 2000 ist eine schwere
waffe die kanzlei bietet 4000 dies auch
und der heißt
leopard zwei varianten die hier zur
diskussion stehen weitreichende
generiert wird der mittlere atelier
raketenwerfer maas hat eine weit größere
reichweite sich auf kampfpanzer könnte
daher auch nach russland hineinwirken
das heißt alle der eskalation spiele die
man durch spielt die rubicon sind ja
schon ganz lange überschritten und das
ist ein relativ kindisches
rückzugsgefechte bundesregierung warum
hier ausgerechnet kampfbahn zu
schützenden panzer und sein sollen muss
auch sagen dass es gibt in europa keine
namen kampfpanzer die man liefern könnte
die die britischen französischen
italienischen kampf an so wie lange
außer produktion sind muss der kleine
stückzahlen vorhanden und das was am
reserve gerät da ist das dient als
ersatzteillager für die bestehenden
verbände das heißt wir haben nur den
leopard 2 der noch in produktion ist
wohl noch nach produzieren kann wo es
ausreichend wirklich eine ausreichende
anzahl an fahrzeugen gibt dass man die
ukraine damit ausstatten könnte weil von
ihrem prozent werks und drei challengers
die noch in großbritannien umschlägen
darstellen stellt sich ja keinen panzer
verband hofft und gibt dieses polen
verschiedener älterer leopard bestände
aus ganz europa würde auch die last
verteilt die das land zu tragen hätte
banzer abzuschmettern mit hier gibt es
ja auch ein bis er wird wohl eher nicht
mehr eingesetzten älteren fahrzeugen
generieren kann die man dann relativ
knappe zeit auch ausfahren kann so dass
sie auch noch rechtzeitig erscheinen der
andere kampfpanzer dienst noch in
größeren mengen gebe zumindest auf dem
papier ist der amerikanische r b er wird
gerade was auch immer fahren kann wird
nach polen geliefert dann diese geräte
waren ja ersatzteillager für den
amerikanischen krieg im irak sind auch
stark mitgenommen und da werden erst
nächstes jahr eigentlich panzer wieder
frei
von der lieferkapazität wie die ukraine
dann erst bekommen könnte dass wir von
der zeitleiste ja es ist also viel zu
viel zu spät und die ukraine könnte die
kampfpanzer jetzt dringend benötigen
auch um weiterhin erfolgreich zu sein
wenn ich sie recht verstehen welche
gebiete sind denn nun strategisch
wichtig damit man tatsächlich oder
wichtig für ein vorrücken der
ukrainischen armee damit man tatsächlich
von einem wendepunkt sprechen könnte
ja die wende dürfte sich schon vollzogen
haben weil durch diese zwei kessel in
klassen und auch lithium russland
dermaßen viel personal verloren hat das
ist jetzt nicht mehr die kräfte hat
große reserven zu bilden bräuchte es
eigentlich um gebiete dauerhaft zu
erhalten das zweite wir haben dem damals
natürlich fluss linie natürliche
flussläufe die die verteidigung
einfacher machen der kleine denn jetzt
ist seine stark verteidigt bahre
schlusslinie die haben die ukraine den
haben die ukraine jetzt wohl immer noch
überschritten und hielt das gibt es
unbestätigte meldungen die sich
allerdings verdichten dass auch dem
süden überschritten worden ist denn
russland ist nicht mehr schafft sich an
solchen
geländehindernissen an solchen
flussläufen festzukrallen und ihre
verteidigungslinie aufzubauen dann ist
im grunde der ganzen erde hans kast
unmittelbar von der rückeroberung
steht unmittelbar vor der rückeroberung
und von dort kann man natürlich dann
auch einfacher gegen süden einschwenken
es gibt noch einmal eine stark
verteidigt bahre linie das ist die alte
kontakt linie die die alten sogenannten
volksrepublik markiert hat in acht
jahren don bosco dies dann auch noch
stark zu verteidigen sollte es den
ukrainern gelingen auch die zu
durchbrechen dann wären grunde das
sozusagen das überleben der beiden
volksgruppen republiken im grunde
besiegelt also es schaut jetzt möglich
sehr dramatisch aus wenn man sich die
front aus russischer sicht anschaut ja
danke für diese klaren worte und die
einschätzung gustav gresse
militärexperte danke für das gespräch
herzlichen dank